el médico que operó al Papa Francisco
confirmó este miércoles en una rueda de
prensa que la operación de una hernia
abdominal a la cual fue sometido el
pontífice salió bien que el papa
reaccionó bien a la anestesia general y
a la cirugía una operación intestinal
que duró tres horas al final de la
intervención quirúrgica el papa se
despertó consciente de buen humor se
trata del mismo médico que lo operó en
2021 y contó que al despertar esta vez
Francisco le hizo una broma le dijo
doctor cuándo programamos la tercera
operación el médico también confirmó que
durante la intervención no se habían
descubierto nuevas patologías y que el
soberano pontífice no debería quedar con
secuelas de ningún tipo como
consecuencia de esta operación Francisco
permanecerá hospitalizado durante varios
días sus audiencias públicas han sido
suspendidas hasta el próximo 18 de junio